we really need a president who is not
the laughingstock of the world then once
again world leaders have been caught on
video laughing at Donald Trump this time
it's Russian President Vladimir Putin
and Syrian dictator Bashar al-assad
remember that it was Donald Trump who
said we need a non laughingstock
president he tweeted back in 2014 when
Barack Obama was president we need a
president who isn't the laughingstock to
the entire world
we need a truly great leader a genius at
strategy and winning respect he claimed
he would be that president here's video
of Putin and Assad laughing at Trump now
of course they're not speaking in
English it's Russian with Putin using
the aid of a translator so I'll
summarize what was said per Axios the
video shows the leaders talking to each
other while visiting the Orthodox Church
of the Virgin Mary in Damascus Assad
tells Putin about the Apostle Paul who
became a Christian at the gate of
Damascus and he jokingly says if Trump
arrives along this road everything will
be normal with him - Putin then laughs
and tells Assad it will be repaired
invite him he will come and Assad
answers he's ready to invite Trump to
which Putin responds smiling I will tell
him and they all laugh and what you have
to understand is the literal translation
doesn't really do it justice let's look
at the video where they are just
laughing and having a grand old time
laughing at Trump then I'll explain the
sort of gist of this
this is happening all the time world
leaders laughing at Trump so the literal
translation doesn't make the joke
totally obvious but it would sort of be
like saying you know you should invite
Trump to visit the road to Damascus if
walking that road led Paul to see the
light maybe it would fix Donald Trump as
well the idea being that Trump is
clueless that's the gist of it remember
that a few months ago Donald Trump left
the NATO summit early after world
leaders including the Canadian Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau French president
Emmanuel macron and British prime
minister Boris Johnson were caught on
video laughing at Trump here's that
video as a reminder
[Music]
[Music]
Trump so triggered by that one that he
left the NATO summit early and then of
course there was the time that the
entire roomful of the United Nations
national assembly laughed at Donald
Trump's ridiculous hyperbole in 2018 a
particularly orange-looking Trump
getting a laugh but he wasn't telling
any jokes today I stand before the
United Nations General Assembly to share
the extraordinary progress we've made in
less than two years my administration
has accomplished more than almost any
administration in the history of our
country America's so true
didn't expect that reaction but that's
okay
weren't we supposed to be getting away
from the laughingstock president by
electing Donald Trump it's the opposite
it's the same projection it's all the
stuff Trump said Obama was doing or
represented or was Trump actually is all
the things that Trump said Hillary would
do if she were to become president Trump
is actually doing while trying to take
credit for things that he actually had
nothing to do with I'm sick of having a
laughingstock president I want to fix
this let's fix it in November